it's so weird though because I feel you
know with the whole acting process that
part there's certain roles that you
really [ __ ] want you know and sex
when you finally have a role that really
resonates with you and you don't get it
and then you see the person that gets
done like yes son of a [ __ ] I see when
the [ __ ] streets [ __ ] out and the
only thing you can do is like yeah yeah
you know I wish him the best man I hope
he does good but deep down inside you're
like you're a lot nicer than me I'm like
I wish the worst appearance you were
going to enjoy this role and it should
have went to me you [ __ ] [ __ ] man
it's hard to play at a Tonya Harding
them [ __ ] deal with that and he's a
wolf or a [ __ ] person in a wheelchair
just higher Khalif Polly [ __ ] kick
his ass sperm yeah I know it's hard man
like I think that you know when I first
started doing the whole acting thing for
the year because I really wanted to
figure out what it was like yeah it was
not easy man I don't know how you've
been doing it for so long because you
know I love doing it you know I think
like it takes a certain kind of person
you know like you know you you you might
have to have like some kind of
masochistic kind of personality yeah you
know to go through you know the ups and
downs and I don't know I like it you
like I like it you know I feel like the
job isn't necessarily the job it is like
the process of trying to get it
mmm not that that's sort of what excites
me you know when there's like when when
there are droughts and I'm not doing
anything he for some reason I like it a
little bit mm-hmm so weird kind of
feeling it's that it's that hunger
feeling right make sure you have some
push towards something yeah and if it
was easy yeah I don't know if I would
like it so much you know if it was like
you know people say like you know is
your hard like being asian-american like
with like all this lack of
representation and whatnot and I'm like
yeah yeah it is but then like if it was
given to me like so easily I don't know
if I would like it so much I sort of
like this challenge it's fun yeah like
navigating this whole system I don't
think you've ever fallen into that
category of somebody who who's ever put
it on their ethnicity for a reason why
you never got to book a role right now
no and I've always hated that attitude
too because I've I've heard that so
often specifically in this industry they
go
I didn't book it because they don't want
people who look like me in this role but
at the same time I mean not gonna call
it any names but I see some of the
people who have been complaining the
loudest I'm like you're the worst actor
I've ever seen in my life I'll [ __ ]
dare you and you know it's funny it
might be the case but then like just
even saying that out loud for yourself
as an artist it just hinders you from
like you know doing better work yeah you
know you just you justify it by saying
oh yeah they they didn't they didn't
cast me because they didn't want an
Asian guy they went in another ethnicity
yeah or maybe they just didn't catch you
because you weren't the right part for
it you weren't good enough yeah no I
think that's a it's a more rational way
for me to think things because if I keep
thinking it's about something that's out
of my control then it makes me go crazy
yeah like what's the point yeah totally
it's such a hard thing to deal with too
it's just like oh it's because I'm Asian
but I would like to hear that from
people who I respect a little more
though yeah you know cuz I think that
people who are booking who do great
things and you look at them and they're
respected in their craft I don't ever
hear them say that [ __ ] and there's a
reason why they're booking I think
justice said it the best - he goes you
know he goes I don't really like to play
this game he goes I just try to get
booked based on my skill yeah so coz if
the skill is there it's gonna eventually
they'll become undeniable eventually
it'll hit something you know I mean um I
mean when before you were before you hit
this this big role on a big series I
mean what's it what's it kind of like I
think as an actor too because people
want to go into this profession what's
it like kind of dealing with not not
being able to book right because I feel
like that's a majority of the acting
game is is its number one to study your
craft in the waiting game yeah I did you
just gotta figure out you know what to
do during that time and it literally is
just continuing to work on your [ __ ] you
know if you think like oh man I don't
think it should be a waiting game and I
think once people start thinking of it
like they're waiting then nothing will
come but if you just keep yourself busy
you don't work on other things and just
try to get better take a class I mean I
think it's just like it's it's it's
working out a muscle man do you ever
like doubt your skill
oh yeah for sure all the time man but
the thing is that that that well what
I've learned though is that you got to
use that hmm and use that doubt and put
it into the character and you start
working on that character as a doubtful
character mm-hmm then that doubt creeps
in as something that's a part of who a
part of that part of that part of that
person you know and so people can't
really see that and he's sort of like
sort of just uh bring it in and put it
into the story and I feel like that has
really helped yeah maybe maybe because
you deal with this so well because like
there's some other people I think that
when because it's such it's it's a
career where you do you are constantly
looking for affirmation all the time
yeah and you don't even get the tips to
why you can't even book some of these
roles so you you're kind of left feeling
lost all the time right and so it's like
how do you become that person where you
still stay confident in your choices
after you leave an audition yeah cuz I
think that's the first thing that
happens to a lot of people who go into
this they go oh I I thought I did really
well what the [ __ ] is it and they can
switch up their game plan yeah the cars
they start switching things they start
thinking like what do they want you
start doing things that they think other
people want to see but I feel like if
you really believe in what you're
bringing to the story then there's no
need to think about anything else and
how you should do things differently
because you never know why they're gonna
put why they're gonna book you you know
you just got to go in and just be very
steadfast in your capability know and
just try to get better and better not
not try to navigate the system and try
to do better so that they'll pick you
because if you keep doing that you're
just gonna keep missing I believe like
you just have to go in like yo this is
what I believe the story is this is what
I believe um you know how the character
would be in this kind of situation and
then you just present that to them yeah
if somebody was trying to be an an actor
let's say like out of the blue what
would be like what would be like a
couple of things you would tell somebody
in order to be like successful and
survive in this industry was something
that you would tell them
man I think it's just you just got to be
very persistent man and you got a you
got to work at it it's not some it's not
about like you know it it's different
from other kinds of art cuz it's not
really a performance mmm you know you're
not going in there and doing like psych
this is a performance you really have to
become you really have to become these
characters so you got to really work on
I guess you got to work on you got to go
take a class man like it's not something
that it's just like oh I'm gonna be an
actor and then some some people some
people become successful that way and
they hit like one big thing but then I
feel like oh like over time you know
it's it's it's gonna expire and I feel
like if you really want to do something
like this you just got to work on your
craft man that's that's pretty much the
the biggest thing I think you know and I
feel like some people think it's just so
easy you know it's like it's like it's
like tell it's like someone saying like
oh I want to be a doctor and then they
go and they think they can be a doctor
like the next week I you know I get
really annoyed when somebody does that
to like like for example I don't know
how many times I met somebody when they
go dude I got this great script idea I
might listen to me shut the [ __ ] like
III I don't want to hear it like I
really don't not to say that maybe your
script idea isn't great but they kind of
I want people to understand that when
you tell that to somebody who is I'm not
a script writer screenwriter right but
when you told that somebody who's a
screenwriter then has worked their ass
off to be where they're at right and you
go I have something that the world
hasn't seen yet and I'm gonna do
something better than you it's like okay
out of all the people in the world why
is it that it would be you I'm not
telling you to self doubt yourself but
have a little bit of self-awareness
because I think people they kind of
don't understand how difficult it is to
either sell a TV show to get a movie
made and have it be really good and they
not without knowing that they kind of
they're your lightweight looking you're
kind of like what's the word I'm looking
for
you guys are not being mindful of how
the work and dedication it takes to be
in that career
yeah it's true man self-awareness is
very key yeah you know what's funny
though is when anyone starts off though
doing any kind of like artistic thing I
think that's sort of what propels them
at first though cuz they think they can
do it they're like [ __ ] yeah I got this
I want to be an actor I can do this and
it's just that just it's just being a
naive just a little bit but then tip but
once they tip they dip their toes into
the field and they realize how crazy it
is then that's when they should start
you know working towards um I don't know
getting better at what they're doing
yeah you know what I mean but sometimes
you know in the beginning it sort of
helps them over you know like it's just
like in ignorance yeah
you know you're like yeah I'm a [ __ ]
like you know I can be a dancer I like
music my body you know like but that's
what propels people to do stuff yeah and
you know I admire that at first but but
you know over time you know you got to
realize that you know there there are so
many other there's so many other things
that that come into play yeah you know
and even even as an actor too it's like
like but why do you want to do in the
first place